malaria kills more than 400 000 people
every year most of them under the age of
five that's one child every two minutes
and despite huge advances in medicine
the best means of protection against the
parasite that causes the disease is a
bed net but that could be about to
change
[Music]
vaccination is one of the triumphs of
modern medicine and now scientists have
the most deadly parasite in their sights
the first jab against malaria
it's a public health historical
event that for the first time a malaria
vaccine can be safely and efficaciously
deployed to save lives of african
children
the vaccine called musquerics primes the
immune system to fight the malaria
parasite the moment it's been injected
into the blood by a mosquito bite it
stops the parasite infecting liver cells
where it would normally mature and
multiply before causing potentially
deadly disease
this is the first vaccine against a
human parasite why well even though it's
only a single celled organism it's a
good deal more complex than a virus or
bacteria for example covid is caused by
a relatively simple virus it's got a
straightforward target on its surface
and covid vaccines teach the immune
system to attack it but the malaria
parasite is able to slip past the immune
system by using a combination of stealth
and deception
this is orders of magnitude more complex
than a covet vaccine or
any of the other vaccines we have today
and the world had never had a vaccine
against a human parasite not just
against malaria against any human
parasite
clinical trials on young children show
it prevents three out of ten severe
cases
now that might not sound that impressive
but malaria is so serious that the world
health organization still believes it
will prevent tens of thousands of deaths
every year
here's the really good news muskrix is
just the first attempt
another vaccine called r21 matrix m is
being developed by the same oxford
university team that developed the
astrazeneca kovid jab
a trial on several hundred children in
bikino faso showed earlier this year
that it prevented 77 of cases a bigger
study is now being planned
malaria a disease caused by a parasite
that's killed hundreds of millions of
people may finally have met its match
[Music]
you